[Musique]
le livre est l'un des plus vendus de
tous les temps l'auteur n'est ni
romancier et dramaturge mais plutôt
pédiatre son nom
[Musique]
l'homme derrière la génération des baby
spock
c'était en 1946 il ya 75 ans
après la seconde guerre mondiale
l'espoir rejaillit incarné par une
effervescence de nouveaux nés benjamines
spock et pédiatre à new york depuis près
de 15 ans à l'époque on recommande pour
l'éducation des enfants une approche
stricte et froide les soumettre à une
routine fixe une pâleur montrer trop
d'affection le docteur spock n'est pas
du même avis le médecin élabore sa
théorie qui présente dans son livre
comme un saint ce beau bébé and child
care ou en français comment soigner
éduquer son enfant
pour lui l'enfant est un être doté de
besoins émotionnels
l'auteur s'adresse aux parents de
manière humaine est compréhensible
une approche pour l'époque
révolutionnaire
les premières lignes de son ouvrage
donne le temps faites vous confiance
vous en savez plus que vous ne le pensez
l'engouement pour les enseignements du
docteur spock et immédiat ces idées se
répandent comme une traînée de poudre
une génération entière d'enfants élevés
sous ses conseils réconfortant voit le
jour
le livre devient un succès mondial
traduit en une quarantaine de langues
mais la réputation du médecin s'effrite
au fil des ans
dans les années soixante et soixante dix
il est accusé d'être à l'origine d'une
génération de jeunes se croyant tout
permis
[Musique]
graduellement plusieurs de ces théories
sont réfutées comme celle selon laquelle
les bébés devraient dormir sur le ventre
le docteur spock temps de corriger le
tir dans les éditions ultérieures de son
livre mais il ne retrouvera jamais sa
crédibilité d'antan
en octobre 2018 vingt ans après le
dessin du célèbre médecin la 10e édition
de son livre paraît une version au goût
du jour où sont notamment abordé
l'adoption internationale et
l'homoparentalité
comme quoi bien au delà de la mort et
les critiques le pédiatre n'a pas dit
son dernier mot ni produit son dernier
bébé scop
[Musique]